thank you
thank you very much everything sorry to
keep you waiting complicated business
complicated
thank you very much
I've just received a call from Secretary
Clinton
she congratulated us it's about us on
our victory and I congratulated her and
her family on a very very hard-fought
campaign I mean she she fought very hard
Hillary has worked very long and very
hard over a long period of time and we
owe her a major debt of gratitude for
her service to our country
I need that very soon now it's time for
America to bind the wounds of division
have to get together to all Republicans
and Democrats and independents across
this nation I say it is time for us to
come together as one United people
I pledge to every citizen of our land
that I will be President for all
Americans and this is so important to me
for those who have chosen not to support
me in the past of which there were a few
people I'm reaching out to you for your
guidance and your help so that we can
work together and unify our great
country as I've said from the beginning
ours was not a campaign but rather an
incredible and great movement made up of
millions of hard-working men and women
who love their country and want a better
brighter future for themselves and for
their family it's a movement comprised
of Americans from all races religions
backgrounds and beliefs who want and
expect our government to serve the
people and serve the people it will
working together we will begin the
urgent task of rebuilding our nation and
renewing the American dream
I've spent my entire life and business
looking at the untapped potential in
projects and in people all over the
world that is now what I want to do for
our country tremendous potential I've
got to know our country so well
tremendous potential it's going to be a
beautiful thing every single American
will have the opportunity to realize his
or her fullest potential they're
forgotten men and women of our country
will be forgotten no longer
we are going to fix our inner cities and
rebuild our highways bridges tunnels
airports schools hospitals we're going
to rebuild our infrastructure which will
become by the way second to none and we
will put millions of our people to work
as we rebuild it
we will also finally take care of our
great veterans we've been so loyal and
I've gotten to know so many over this
18-month journey the time I've spent
with them during this campaign has been
among my greatest honors our veterans
are incredible people we will embark
upon a project of national growth and
renewal
I will harness the creative talents of
our people and we will call upon the
best and brightest to leverage their
tremendous talent for the benefit of all
it's going to happen we have a great
economic plan we will double our growth
and have the strongest economy anywhere
in the world at the same time we will
get along with all other nations willing
to get along with us we'll have great
relationships we expect to have great
great relationships no dream is too big
no challenge is too great nothing we
want for our future is beyond our reach
America will no longer settle for
anything less than the best
reclaim country's destiny and dream big
and bold and daring we have to do that
we're going to dream of things for our
country and beautiful things and
successful things once again I want to
tell the world community that while we
will always put America's interests
first we will deal fairly with everyone
with everyone all people and all other
nations we will seek common ground not
hostility partnership not conflict and
now I'd like to take this moment to
thank some of the people who really
helped me with this what they are
calling tonight very very historic
victory first I want to thank my parents
who I know are looking down on me right
now
I've learned so much from them they were
wonderful in every regard I had truly
great parents I also want to thank my
sisters Mary Ann and Elizabeth we're
here with us tonight
and where are they they're here
someplace
they're very shy actually and my brother
Robert my great friend where's Robert
where is Robert my brother Robert and
they should all be on this stage but
that's okay they are great and also my
late brother Fred great guy fantastic
though fantastic family I was very lucky
great brothers sisters great
unbelievable parents to Melania and died
and Ivanka
and Eric
and Tiffany
and baron
I love you and I thank you and
especially for putting up with all of
those hours this was tough this was
tough this political stuff is nasty and
it's tough so I want to thank my family
very much really fantastic thank you all
thank you all and Lera unbelievable job
unbelievable Vanessa thank you thank you
very much what a great group you've all
given me such incredible support and I
will tell you that we have a large group
of people you know they kept saying we
have a small staff that's so small look
at all the people that we have look at
all of these people and Kellyanne and
Chris and Rudy and Steve and David we
have got we have got tremendously
talented people up here and I want to
tell you it's been it's been very very
special I want to give a very special
thanks to our former Mayor Rudy Giuliani
unbelievable he traveled with us and he
went through meetings he that really
never changed it where's Rudy where is
it Rudy Governor Chris Christie folks
was
thank you good the first man first
senator first major major politician and
let me tell you he is highly respected
in Washington because he's as smart as
you get Senator Jeff Sessions
great man another great man very tough
competitor he was not easy he was not
easy
who is that is that the bear that showed
up Rudy got up here another great man
who has been really a friend to me but
I'll tell you I got to know him as a
competitor because he was one of the
folks that was negotiating to go against
those Democrats dr. ben Carson where's
back and by the way Mike Huckabee is
here someplace and he's Santa Mike and
his family Sarah thank you very much
general Mike Flynn and general Kellogg
we have over 200 generals and admirals
that have endorsed our campaign and
there's special people and it's really
an honor we have 22 Congressional Medal
of Honor recipients we have just
tremendous people a very special person
who believed me and you know I'd read
reports that I wasn't getting along with
him I never had a bad second with him
he's an unbelievable star he is that's
right how did you possibly guess so
let me tell you about Rice and I've said
this I said rights and I know it I know
it look at all those people over there I
know it rights is a superstar but I said
they can't call you a superstar rights
unless we win because you can't be
called a superstar like Secretariat if
Secretariat came in second Secretariat
would not have that big beautiful bronze
bus at the track at Belmont but I'll
tell you Rice is really a star and he is
the hardest-working guy
and in a certain way I did this rights
come up here where is right get over
here oh boy oh boy oh boy it's about
time you did this right
ladies and gentlemen the next president
of the United States Donald Trump thank
you it's been an honor
god bless thank God
amazing guy our partnership with the RNC
was so important to the success and what
we've done so I also have to say I've
gotten to know some incredible people
the Secret Service people they're tough
and they're smart and they're sharp and
I don't want to mess around with them I
can tell you and when I want to go and
wave to a big group of people and they
rip me down and put me back down to the
sea but they are fantastic people so I
want to thank the Secret Service
and law enforcement in New York City
they're here tonight these are
spectacular people sometimes
underappreciated unfortunately but we
appreciate them we know what they go
through so it's been what they call a
historic event but to be really historic
we have to do a great job and I promise
you that I will not let you down we will
do a great job look very much forward to
being your president and hopefully at
the end of two years or three years or
four years or maybe even eight years
you will say so many of you work so hard
for us but you will say that you will
say that that was something that you
really were very proud to do and and I
can thank you very much and I can only
say that while the campaign is over our
work on this movement is now really just
beginning we're going to get to work
immediately for the American people and
we're going to be doing a job that
hopefully you will be so proud of your
president you'll be so proud again it's
my honor it was an amazing evening it's
been an amazing two-year period and I
love this country